segora came everywhere last year and
recently just released a full
documentary about the entire process the
31 minute video was uploaded to the ymh
YouTube channel last week and details
Tom's entire Journey completing one of
the biggest world tours in stand-up
comedy history after being on the road
for over two years spanning hundreds of
cities Tom came in front of thousands of
people all over the world every night
this monsters tour coming to a finish
has been a huge load off Tom's back and
the new mini documentary contains all
the behind the scenes footage comedy
fans have been dying to see from all the
times that